appears unlikely clark county schools
will return to in-person learning
anytime soon
last night trustees were briefed on the
district's coronavirus response
back in july you'll remember the board
set strict requirements for reopening
schools
those requirements include a five
percent or lower positivity rate
and a downward trend in cases for 14
days
a doctor with the southern nevada health
district said last night clark county
isn't
close to any of those benchmarks however
he says he would
support the board's decision to return
if they have a plan for limiting
capacity
and social distancing board members made
it clear there's no easy answer
would it be more safe for everybody to
keep schools
closed or at least only partially open
um i don't know i just feel really
uncomfortable with this whole thing
and it doesn't seem like there's a lot
of answers and i really don't like the
answer of
just reopen because it's not going to
get better this
year the school board plans to vote on
the future of in-person learning
november 12th